what's the most emotional reaction
you've gotten where you've given someone
money and the reaction was not what
you've expected
um it's actually early on when I tipped
a pizza delivery guy 10 grand yeah and
then he's just you don't really react
too much but then the next day he came
back and I was like oh God was he gonna
ask for more money I was like [ __ ] and I
didn't want to answer but I answered it
anyways
um and because I filmed where I slept
which was very weird but that was when I
was poor
um and he just was like I opened the
door and he just started crying and he
was like I didn't even think this money
was real and he's like I just took
tomorrow off work and I haven't seen my
kids in so long because I work every day
and like I just got to spend a day with
my daughter and he's just like this is
the greatest day of my life I'm so happy
and I was like and then he hugged me and
he's crying and tears are going down my
shirt and I'm like I don't even know
what to like do I was just like
wow
um and so that was that was like even
I'm tearing up a little bit just
thinking oh dude it's touching me yeah
yeah so like that was like the craziest
reaction 10 grand you gave him a day
with his kids exactly and I'm like
opening my door I'm trying to be like
bro I don't have more money yeah and
then he hits me with that and I just
like 180 like so quick I was like [ __ ]
feels better than any car feels better
than any shirt or any [ __ ] expensive
pair of pants it's still better than
what I give people a million dollars
nothing beats that one yeah do you find
yourself chasing that a little bit like
yeah it's fun yeah it's fun it's like I
think people overplay it a lot of people
my situation would be like yeah I just I
love giving and it's the greatest thing
ever and it brings about and like and
even like PR people when I do talk to
them they're always like you should play
it up more and actually and it's just
like no it just it like it just feels
good like it's not like this crazy thing
I'm sure if I did heroin it'd feel
better yeah it's just like in the moment
it feels good and it makes me happy and
yeah I like it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I love that dude and and you don't have
video of when he came back huh no I
didn't even better
yeah it's that but it's also like when
we do that oh now I get exposed to a lot
of it because our food pantry and what's
interesting is like you know a lot of
people their thoughts of this are like
oh it's freeloaders or people who get
like why don't they just get jobs or
they're just leaching but like a lot of
them when I this when I'm there and
working on it it's like you'll see like
a lot of old ladies who back when they
um came up it was just normal for the
guy to work the job they raise the kids
and then now here they are 80 years old
their husband just passes and their
income's totally gone and so it's like
all right I have food rent uh phone bill
this and this you know one of them's got
to go but if you give them free food
then they can afford the other four
things so it's like they're always
really emotional because it's like
literally like do I stop paying for my
phone bill or rent yeah or food and like
obviously you gotta pay for food but if
you give them like 100 worth of food for
free now they can you know put 50
towards rent 50 towards their phone bill
and they're great yeah you are [ __ ]
amazing I mean that's awesome that's so
that's so [ __ ] whenever you get to
hell like this might be personal but
like whenever you get to help like a
single parent or like a single mom does
that connect with you in a different way
because you can empathize no
no it kind of hits the same it's I just
like when they smile and they're really
happy it just makes me happy you know
what I mean um I mean it's the greatest
feeling ever it's this is what I live
for I'm only gonna help people I can
play it up but no it just makes me feel
good and how often are you helping
people like personally like not through
like the other branches but like off
camera where you just like do you ever
like just see a homeless guy and you're
like yeah bro yeah tons like I feel like
people will see that people will judge
you and they'll be like
he wouldn't be doing it I'm like how do
you know that yeah what are you also so
wet yeah yeah are you doing it yeah but
even yeah and that's where it's like how
much content I gotta make dip [ __ ] yeah
but but if I listed the things I do I
want you to speak on that because I
think it's the purpose because then it
looks like it just did it yeah
can you do it on his behalf like have
you ever seen him just like yeah but
that's the thing it's so funny when they
just like Twitter it's Twitter of all
the places where the like they just make
crazy assumptions and like
um they're just like nah if the camera
wasn't there or or Mr Beast is evil and
it's like only nice guys are people who
want to look nice they're all evil or
whatever like things it's like what do
you even mean by that yeah like I'll see
a tweet sometimes like a thousand likes
like you know Mr Beast is evil like no
one's that nice I'm like what
they're normally not
you're so brave you are rare you are a
unicorn I don't take compliments while
I'm like you yeah
no but I think you are rare and that's
good it's amazing yeah does it ever get
you down though you read a tweet no it
must be evil and you're like probably
just spent all day building a food
pantry and now I'm reading this [ __ ] not
as much no honestly like if you're not
getting hate you're just irrelevant so
the fact like it's just part of it so
I've I've actually gotten really numb to
it and probably to a fault where I just
it does nothing to me because it's like
if you know what you're doing is what
you want to do and preach you
fulfillment you're not doing anything
wrong why does it matter you know like I
don't I don't need to prove to this guy
that it is
um and so yeah I'm like super numb to it
right and that's where sometimes people
will show me things and I'll read it I'm
doing okay and I'll just keep going it's
like what do you want me to do see your
[ __ ] cry you know because you
probably do that with a good compliment
too like Mr Beast is saving the world
and you're like you're taking that in
stride too we're like oh I can't believe
that influencers 98 of their comments
are great they don't remember seeing one
of those they just remember the one to
two percent they're not bad and like
proportionately like a 90 plus percent
approval rating is [ __ ] phenomenal
yeah you're killing it you can be
president with yeah you could that's
like unheard of before like you know
Modern Times And so
um yeah I think like more people need to
just take that mindset if majority like
me the criticism I get isn't even valid
who the [ __ ] cares keep doing what
you're doing you know what I mean yeah
assuming it's actually invalid you know
yeah as long as you're proud of what
you're doing yeah well you're not
hurting people and blah blah yeah yeah
yeah and you're not secretly evil when
Twitter claims you're evil bro when you
put out these cartoons they're gonna be
like I told you
[Laughter]
three months from now if we he doesn't
believe it we just see that as a thing
Russian
I have like a hateful Spike towards you
forever
Graham put him in a video an Oscar
it's a world-renowned filmmaker doing it
and he's just like oh yeah I just heard
it on the shield podcast
Christopher Nolan's new movie
is listening I mean are you upset with
that Russian kid that bites all your
[ __ ] oh yeah you know what I'm talking
there's this Russian kid that literally
copies every video
Oh Well it happens really I mean it's
like everyone I don't know like they
could be taking other people's [ __ ] oh a
lot of people not even just like other
countries just like even here it's like
I upload a video on like 200 people
instantly do the same thing like the
next day like introverbatim and
everything but it's also like
who I don't know that comes with success
yeah like obviously it works what I'm
doing works so they're gonna copy I
can't be like hey stop making money I
mean like it sucks that they can't put
their own creative Twist on it and come
up with an original way but yeah oh well
yeah it's like they're better things for
me to worry about like I feel like of
all the problems like people copying me
because I'm winning is a good problem
right you know do you feel like it
impacts the platform like I've heard
people talk about oh the beastification
I I think people need to take what I do
and put their own twist on it because
there are a lot of people who are just
exact rip-offs of me and it is annoying
like I don't care that you do what I do
it doesn't matter but it's like just in
general put your own twist on it it does
annoy people like these videos get
enough views we don't need more me we
need more original people for you yeah
like take what you like about me and do
it but don't just copy my intros
verbatim my thumbnails were random and
just be a rip-off of me like it just
yeah it has a whole it just makes the
platform seem repetitive right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that is so it's like but
also part of why it's so bad is because
I don't care and I let people do it yeah
but I think I've done it to a fault
where now so many people do it and it's
lucrative probably yeah it is like there
are people who make millions of dollars
just literally ripping off what I do so
it's like if I'm letting get to this
point because I'm just like you know I'm
just gonna stay in my Lane do me like
Jeff Bezos says focus on your your
viewers not your competitors yeah and
then I look up and now there's tons of
them it's like you know yeah maybe
someone should roast them a little bit
like someone like everyone's like oh Mr
Beast is never gonna put us in check can
you react to them bro
what is the algorithm that probably
helps them out because like say if
somebody finds one of those people first
and then they're gonna be like oh well
if you like this content you're like
this other video
oh real sweet here yeah yeah that's
interesting